this weekend more than 80 people were
killed or wounded in two evil attacks
one Saturday morning in El Paso Texas a
wicked man went to a Walmart store where
families were shopping with their loved
ones he shot and murdered 20 people and
injured 26 others including precious
little children then in the early hours
of Sunday morning Dayton Ohio another
twisted monster opened fire on a crowded
downtown street he murdered nine people
including his own sister and injured 27
others the first lady and I joined all
Americans in praying and grieving for
the victims their families and the
survivors we will stand by their side
forever we will never forget these
barbaric slaughters are an assault upon
our communities an attack upon our
nation and a crime against all of
humanity we are outraged and sickened by
this monstrous evil the cruelty the
hatred the malice the bloodshed and the
terror our hearts are shattered for
every family whose parents children
husbands and wives were ripped from
their arms and their lives America weeps
for the Fallen we are a loving nation
and our children are entitled to grow up
in a just peaceful and loving society
together we lock arms to shoulder the
grief we ask God in heaven to ease the
anguish of those who suffer and we vow
to act with urgent resolve I want to
thank the many law-enforcement personnel
who responded to these atrocities with
the extraordinary grace and courage
of American heroes I have spoken with
Texas governor Greg Abbott and Ohio
Governor Mike DeWine as well as mayor D
Margo of El Paso Texas and mayor nan
Whaley of Dayton Ohio to express our
profound sadness and unfailing support
today we also send the condolences of
our nation to president Oh Brad or of
Mexico and all the people of Mexico for
the loss of their citizens in the El
Paso shooting terrible terrible thing I
have also been in close contact with
attorney general Barr and FBI director
ray federal authorities are on the
ground and I have directed them to
provide any and all assistance required
whatever is needed the shooter in El
Paso posted a manifesto online consumed
by racist hate in one voice our nation
must condemn racism bigotry and white
supremacy these sinister ideologies must
be defeated hate has no place in America
hatred warps the mind ravages the heart
and devours the soul we have asked the
FBI to identify all further resources
they need to investigate and disrupt
hate crimes and domestic terrorism
whatever they need we must recognize
that the Internet has provided a
dangerous Avenue to radicalize disturbed
minds and perform demented X we must
shine light on the dark recesses of the
internet and stop mass murders before
they start the internet likewise is used
for human trafficking illegal drug
distribution and so many other heinous
crimes the perils of the internet and
social media
cannot be ignored and they will not be
ignored in the two decades since
Columbine our nation has watched with
rising Hara and read as one mass
shooting has followed another over and
over again decade after decade we cannot
allow ourselves to feel powerless we can
and will stop this evil contagion in
that task we must honor the sacred
memory of those we have lost by acting
as one people open wounds cannot heal if
we are divided we must seek real
bipartisan solutions we have to do that
in a bipartisan manner that will truly
make America safer and better for all
first we must do a better job of
identifying and acting on early warning
signs I am directing the Department of
Justice to work in partisan partnership
with local state and federal agencies as
well as social media companies to
develop tools that can detect mass
shooters before they strike as an
example the monster in the Parkland High
School in Florida had many red flags
against him and yet nobody took decisive
action nobody did anything why not
second we must stop the glorification of
violence in our society this includes
the gruesome and grisly video games that
are now commonplace it is too easy today
for troubled youth to surround
themselves with a culture that
celebrates violence
we must stop or substantially reduce
this and it has to begin immediately
cultural change is hard but each of us
can choose to build a culture that
celebrates the inherent Worth and
dignity of every human life that's what
we have to do third we must reform our
mental health laws to better identify
mentally disturbed individuals who may
commit acts of
and make sure those people not only get
treatment but when necessary involuntary
confinement mental illness and hatred
pulls the trigger
not the gun fourth we must make sure
that those judged to pose a grave risk
to public safety do not have access to
firearms and that if they do those
firearms can be taken through rapid due
process that is why I have called for
red flag laws also known as extreme risk
protection orders today I'm also
directing the Department of Justice to
propose legislation ensuring that those
who commit hate crimes and mass murders
face the death penalty and that this
capital punishment be delivered quickly
decisively and without years of needless
delay these are just a few of the areas
of cooperation that we can pursue I am
open and ready to listen and discuss all
ideas that will actually work and make a
very big difference Republicans and
Democrats have proven that we can join
together in a bipartisan fashion to
address this plank last year we enacted
the stop school violence and fix Nick's
acts into law providing grants to
improve school safety and strengthening
critical background checks for firearm
purchases at my direction the Department
of Justice banned bump stocks last year
we prosecuted a record number of
firearms offenses but there is so much
more that we have to do now is the time
to set destructive partisanship aside so
destructive and find the courage to
answer hatred with unity devotion and
love our future is in our control
America will rise to the challenge we
will always have
and we always will win the choices ours
and ours alone it is not up to mentally
ill monsters it is up to us that we are
able to pass great legislation after all
of these years we will ensure that those
who were attacked will not have died in
vain may God bless the memory of those
who perished in Toledo I may God protect
them may God protect all of those from
Texas to Ohio may God bless the victims
and their families may God bless america
thank you very much thank you